>> That's a very good answer, David. First of all, your answer is correct.
And in addition, you were able to point out that there is no slot here which is
able to take care of the information coming in as input about her dad.
Before we worry about what information that Angela had lasagna with her dad.
Let us look at some of the properties of frames. So once again there are slots.
You can put fillers in the slots. Each filler may come from a range of values.
Some of these slots have default fillers. Now you can see how some kind of
common sense inferences become possible. Some of them become possible from these
default fillers for these slots. So for example, when we said Ashok ate a frog,
and David answered the question whether the frog was dead or alive by saying
the frog was dead. Well, we know about it because there is a default value here,
the object that has been eaten is not alive, it's false to say it's alive.
And the location of the object after it has been eaten is inside the subject's
stomach, or inside the subject's body. And so on. We could put here more slots,
with more default values for them. Once again, we'll discuss a lot more about
common sense reasoning a little bit later in this particular course. For now,
we are trying to understand the knowledge and presentation of frames.